OK, let me just briefly mention this, because
it is this is a really big story. Donald Trump
has turned on his own. Vice President Donald
Trump has denounced his own vice president,
Mike Pence. And there are reports coming from
from the White House that Donald Trump is
absolutely furious with Mike Pence. I'm not
aware. And I looked to spent some time today
looking in a very crazy, crazy day. I did
want to research this to some degree. I've
not been able to find another instance of
a president turning on a vice president to
this degree in American history. Donald Trump
yesterday, again in a tweet that ultimately
was removed by Twitter because it was making
false claims.
Donald Trump turning on his own vice president,
saying, quote, Mike Pence didn't have the
courage to do what should have been done to
protect our country and our institution, giving
states a chance to certify a corrected set
of facts, not the fraudulent or inaccurate
ones which they were asked to previously certify.
USA demands the truth. I have never seen anything
like this, and I've found nothing like this
in the historical record. The president of
the United States turning on his vice president.
Now, we'll talk later about this. This was
very good news for many Republicans. As I've
been telling you, many Republicans are looking
for an escape pod. I'm not defending Republicans
in any way, but I recognize that some of them
feel like, how do I break from Trump? How
do I I need something to open the door to
break from Trump. Trump denouncing Pence is
exactly that, where now the writing is on
the wall.
Trump is going to basically shrink away for
the last two weeks of his presidency. Pence,
by being denounced by Trump now, is the person
that, quote, normal Republicans can side with.
And many of them taking that opportunity,
seeing a number of different Trump staffers
come out and say, we agree with Mike Pence.
We've seen some resignations. There are theories
that more resignations are coming. So I am
not at every single one of these Republicans
is disgusting because they should have had
the testicular fortitude or the ovarian fortitude
to step away and denounce it. Four years ago
they didn't, but.
This is they've opened the escape hatch as
Trump has denounced Pence, and these are truly,
truly historic days. So we'll continue covering
all of these stories. We have much more today.
Let
me
know
your thoughts.